I hope,
uh,
and I,
and I don't mean this
lightly,
but I hope that when I think about my
contribution legacy,
that the
first thing is that my kids will say,
you know,
was pretty good guy.
Um,
and,
and will quote me,
you know,
in,
in your dad,
always used to say,
or I remember some time when dad said,
uh,
that would be one piece.
I remember going to Rome the first time
and making a point of seeing keats's
grave and weeping.
It keeps his grave.
And I did because,
you know,
there it is.
I mean,
he craved and mortality and on his
tombstone is written here lies one whose
name was written water.
And you never know whether Kate's was,
you know,
I actually thought that or whether he
was doing that,
figuring that if by doing that,
you know,
sort of like taking an umbrella so it
wouldn't rain.
Um,
uh,
whether he,
that was a protection or whether he was,
whether,
whether it was just false modesty.
But,
but I'd like to think that in some of
the work that I've done both in my own
writing and as the editor of Hbr,
that there will be a few things that
have changed some organizations for the
better,
you know,
when I was at,
fortunately before coming to Hbr,
I wrote two books about intellectual
capital and about the value of knowledge
and the importance of thinking of
knowledge in organizations and
developing knowledge assets and
developing,
using,
tapping into people's brains and
creativity worth.
And those have had an influence I think
along with a lot of other things.
I may have contributed to that.
But I also,
I hope that in that work and,
and in the work I've done at Hbr,
they'll be some people who say,
you know,
that article or that idea that,
that,
that changed things that,
that gave people some stuff that made
some lives better.
Or,
or even ideally some organizations,
you know,
I'm a change changed the practice of
management in some permanent way so that
we stop screwing things up quite as
often as we did.